okay it should by psychobabble by
playing Kim escaped episode 1 Satan's
and that plays a long time ago so yes so
let's see if I can go through is kind of
fast everything you taught you change
everything I'll take this thank you
nothing here nothing here nothing here
I'll take this ma'am thank you
no nobody knows the answer to that
I missed that Friday I get that's right
I miss thank you nap nap nap I'll take
this one I take this bad friend
I like this candle but this right here
Lara you know you just gotta do what you
gotta do
Harvey's eggs any case here now
no case here take this um I Karis not my
someone where is that I know you have it
where is that as well she said
- okay good
hope you are happy up where the heck is
last I know it's here I know it's a
right here somewhere not there
not behind here that ain't you behind
these pieces can ieave how his ex now
get away from me
you hear why it is like that noise I
know why you like that it hadn't okay I
got it
well that's just standing there for a
second okay yeah cook it honey up
perhaps
okay
cocked egg butter right there
check this bad hello sir
Oh God
[Music]
fascinating but I need to get the last
pace the picture is not compliant you
know that sounds like something they
would say anything now they're not those
are nothing here there should be
something here
ah thank you
stupid vaults everywhere
turn the lights
some are not 1071 what is that finger
can you help me answer thought apiece
I'll take that thank you I thought okay
thank you
I'll chase that
[Music]
one four eight seven I have it
he's angry tonight what's this down here
can I find any up like that what is that
don't know all
remember that song maybe okay Bam Bam
Bam Bam
bow-bow bow-bow bow-bow
can you guys back that's how high
[Music]
turn off those lights that are doing
something call up
[Music]
and anymore feel like I should have more
um I ran this sure
[Music]
hmm there you go
I need a Kip I just made a cap now how
about buddy well he has anger right
today
[Music]
what far it's seven a lot master shrimp
chili Jack you look great
don't turn the stove off and I can't
fall 9 1071
nope I gotta dig here nope
Thank You sucker I got you yeah click I
Oh what
there was such a jerk to me
I can't turn this off same old story
same old story
I feel like I'm missing a lot of photo
pieces now
we're out there something terrible or
see like Michael half-crowns AG up six
first one two four five right yep
five what is that before it thank you
not great what's dripping hello sir
[Music]
[Music]
dome enough pieces now
but I'm the one that was just falling I
get that I love a can i right pick that
up
I picked that up
know what unaffected I think that's not
hello sir
I don't know what is going on yeah
Charlie
[Music]
I wish I might know the answers from me
but a virtual I they're not artists
get out of there
Lanta nine ten oh great when this music
is intense
okay
okay past here sometimes
yes
what one time thank you
hello sir alright let's get crazy this
is gonna pose arc
Shea's a past nope
I say yeah and I want to say it but I
say yeah is that as bang
okay
okay you're right the stuff 10 at 11:25
his spring
9:05 is lady
3:55 is like okay guess we're doing this
okay 11:25
most narrow vibe
okay because this one off real quick
I'm gonna fry you know sorry
Harris I have a 1 4 8 7 an Anna yeah
that that would 1 4 8 7 okay
[Music]
let's hangar down Jenna have it a left
and tell you
panel honor thank dance
get out of here get out of here step at
back
karemera what the heck happens now okay
anyway hello let's get back out of here
summer
it's the like 355 tank now this is like
a bad light okay hello again
[Music]
and 11:25 right
okay wait and see how this is gone this
is growling now let's see how is it
going
okay I gotta mess with that then he's
got a present dang okay I got prozac
from that melting I got the cactus fruit
Harvey never left
and I frayed this guy now Harvey's dead
so it's gotta be before then summer
[Music]
I sell stock what is that
Zeki here no I still didn't use the
other one so there's gotta be stuff in
here with this hanger yeah oh sorry
yeah
all right all right get out of here yet
don't just say I don't want your hand
anymore
hey bucked areas
thank you
okay do I have everything no okay well
cause where one goes to flower all right
yeah wait I have the flower look at a
yogurt one goes to flower all right oh
wait am I like in the wrong thing
hey one
okay
cactus goes up to
how do I got rather water
not very sure not to get rid of water
there we go
fruit juice goes to two
Prozac okay
Prozac juice goes to 4 which means
mushroom sauce goes here perfect okay
I got you sucker
yeah right now it is nice in here
my entire 1981
and thank you thank you